now i remember when we were doing shows
together like because i kind of started
that thing
when when you would be performing you
would say about how you had stopped
drinking yeah you were drinking you
would drink a duels all the time yeah um
so i haven't drank alcohol i i started
drinking wine again about two years ago
that's alcohol it is it is
wait what yeah no it's not it's a
breakfast your pork is great
it's great you're wrong there's grapes
it's fermented grapes
fermented grapes
i would do coke yeah
no i i drink wine um but i haven't drank
it when she went to mexico napa valley
sober yeah
i'm sonoma sobra
what's crystal meth maintenance
[Music]
oh man you can come up with these all
day long no but i haven't drank beer
nine years or eight years i haven't had
any like whiskey
drinking alcohol
what was it that made you stop drinking
in the first place
so i stopped drinking all together
everything for six years
um because you had an issue with alcohol
well here's the thing is
doing like what we've done for so long
like we got paid to party we we drank
every day it was a part of what we did
and then i got to the point where when i
stopped i actually just basically had a
like i would say like some sort of like
mental breakdown where i lost
my
my mind like i i think something i
remember i think i remember and you were
telling me i have a problem with alcohol
well it wasn't a problem with alcohol it
was the see i was a functioning i was
what you could consider a functioning
alcoholic i'd have i'd be on tour with
bands you know shooting photos and doing
my thing and i could
i could do i could have like five five
to ten jack and cokes every night ten
jack and cokes every night like
whatever no big deal and i would perform
i could do my stuff but every day i woke
up and i had this like just dehydrated
feeling and my body was you know all the
voices in your head were
cranked up i got to the point where it
was groundhog's day and i felt no hope
for
for no
way out and
i literally lost it where i took myself
to the emergency room and i said i
because i
something in my brain kind of just like
had enough in it
i went like a little psychosis and then
um you know they wanted to to
help me there and put me in a you know
a place where they like the sane asylum
i guess it would be considered um and i
said
no uh i'm gonna take care of this myself
and that day
i stopped drinking i stopped drinking it
all together i hadn't drank since that
time for six years and and it was to the
point at which i
really don't think i could have survived
if i didn't because i was so depressed
because i just felt
so hopeless so no way out no way out
today you know when you wake up and
you're like i'm so hungover i'm never
drinking again and then that now you're
drinking again and i'm so going over and
when you get in that cycle with whatever
it is you're doing and there's just that
idea of nothing's going to change and
there's no hope
you literally like i snapped i lost it
and and that is what cured me is that i
realized
that i
the only person that will do this the
only person that can fix this is me like
and then there's people that can help
along the way for sure i believe that
but it comes down to you you're you're
with yourself 24 7. you know what you
dream you know what your visions are
your goals you know when you're doing
wrong and if every morning you wake up
thinking i did it again it just doesn't
give you a chance to have a good day
i mean
i think that the definition of
alcoholism is when you are
genuinely powerless to stop and you know
it sounds like you were a problem
drinker and you found a real
reason to
to to stop her or moderate and you're
able to do so and and that's great yeah
like that there's like a level of
alcoholism where
no amount of willpower can ever help you
but it's but it's but the thing is so
weird is that i wasn't a problem drinker
and that's the i think
the worst alcoholic or person who drinks
alcohol does any kind of drugs or
anything the substances are those that
can function with it for no no oh my god
absolutely bottom drunk because well no
no i mean here's the thing it just never
stopped i i was the luckiest
because you were just i was like
because for me it was so goddamn bad
that it had to stop and because it had
to stop i'd surrendered to the process
of recovery and and and got better yeah
and when you surrender to the process of
recovery like when you treat alcoholism
you somehow become a better version of
yourself than you were before you
suffered from it yeah and the worst
situation is when you have alcoholism
slash addiction but not so bad because
it's not so bad it doesn't absolutely
have to stop and it never does stop and
the years slipped through your baby and
you're dead that's yours turned into
decades slipping through your fingers
and then you turn around you're like
what the [ __ ] did i do with my life i
blew it yeah did you ever have you ever
done so many psychedelics you thought
you never coming back i can tell you you
i bro you you i mean it took you years
to come back yeah okay you weren't you
now who you are or before for
four years dude probably after when you
when you finally went to do this right
to sober living in rehab and
i mean dude how many times do you
remember going to india and we're
sitting next to each other on the plane
and i was telling you this i'm like bro
you're a good dude like you you have so
much you're you're blowing it you're you
don't even know who your name right now
and you're like [ __ ] yeah
but then but then when you got to that
point at which you got to help and you
went through the process
for like three or four years we're still
kind of like
this in-between guy it was like
check this out when uh
like
i was in
treatment i was like rehabs and psych
wards for six months okay and um
when i got
at the end of that six months i moved
into a sober living yeah right so then
so once i got out of the six months and
into the sober living then i was sort of
free to go to go around and i went and
and uh spoke at the um salvation army
where all these people the most low
bottom
like alcoholics and addicts are in rehab
which is free and it's just like the
most like kind of dingiest place where
you can get better this is the low
bottom people and i'm there like
carrying the message telling my story of
recovery six months sober
and uh
yeah i thought it was fine and then
three months later now i'm nine months
sober i go back
and uh
and they they're some of the guys are
still there they're like dude steve oh
man we've
we were here when you're here like we
were worried about you
yeah they were worried about your sober
dude if you could have seen yourself bro
i'm telling you for like for quite some
time yeah you were lower than those
dudes that you're saying are low like
[ __ ] like you were
like like what yeah
just like just
not even human like i don't even like i
don't know i was like steve what was the
first thing you bought with like your
money he's like oh dude like a
refrigerator full of vodka and budweiser
it wasn't the first thing but but uh i
bought a house and you bought a fridge
with butter
it was actually pretty pretty uh
shortly before i got sober one of the
last things i bought was a [ __ ] huge
full tall sized fridge that had the like
that the left side was like freezer from
top to bottom one door
you know there's equal space for the
freezer vodka and beer so the freezer
was full you couldn't fill another
bottle of vodka into it from top to
bottom and then and then the right side
was the fridge and you couldn't
on the apartment the skate department
that was in
[ __ ] fountain that was in my office
apartment oh i had the the skate park
apartment the office department was in
that building
yeah and the assistant apartment what
was your vodka of choice when you drank
like that [ __ ] i think it was grey goose
in there the whole thing so grigoose and
budweiser gray goose and budweiser yeah
wow it's [ __ ] dirty i mean see but
that you you that that you can recognize
as a problem like and that's like you
when you hit rock bottom or multiple
times hit rock bottom
you it's like everyone around you now is
like saying you have a problem but when
you're just floating through
and everyone's like oh he's cool yeah
yeah
right now
being sober if you do something wrong
like you're bummed about it you make it
right later but like when you were [ __ ]
when you were [ __ ] up was there any of
that like feeling bad like [ __ ] i gotta
make it right with this person or was it
he didn't feel bad for anything
if anything he felt better feeling bad
like he like would make people feel like
[ __ ] and love it i would i don't know
that i would love it
i don't know you were pretty stoked
every time you did something [ __ ] up
like really i think
yeah yeah i did it like i was i
definitely became capable of being
pretty pretty mean-spirited yeah and
trying to hurt people's feelings and
like harm their reputations like i did
some [ __ ] up [ __ ] and
ultimately that's what got me sober more
than anything was because i became so
[ __ ] ashamed of all that [ __ ] that i
had done i just like never wanted to be
that person again and so that like
motivated me to really dive into
everything that people do but like what
we're talking about right now and you
you asked me like how did i stop
drinking when i stopped and yeah i drink
wine now but i'm responsible in whatever
portal
yeah i'm important silver or sonoma
silva can we get a shirt made this is
portland sober yeah with the wine glass
cheers
but the thing is is like every person
i don't care how
down you are how [ __ ] up you are you
have that opportunity to make a choice
any every day today tomorrow you do it's
life's not over you have that choice
dude and if you start today listen you
know it's real if you start today and
live for the future and just
don't live from for what you have didn't
do in the past or what you've been doing
and you just start over start over like
today is my new life
i think it's possible that everybody can
get better and clean up like whatever
their problems they have isn't it yeah i
mean like
it doesn't really
translate to alcoholism and drug
addiction because we've had millions
upon millions of people come before us
and show that like really there's only
one way to to to treat that and it's you
can't do it alone you got to do it as a
collective as a group
i stopped drinking cold turkey
but then that just means that you are
like uh
you know not really i think we all have
that ability i really do everybody has
an ability to turn their life around and
i think it's as [ __ ] up as you are
that's the exact opposite is true of how
[ __ ] rad you can get yeah you know
what i mean and it's usually the people
that are the
worst becoming true
yeah i think that clip was awesome but
not as awesome as my new book a hard
kick in the nuts what i've learned from
a lifetime of terrible decisions which
is out september 27th and if you
pre-order it right now you can get the
autographed copy so get on it man
pre-order my book it's not going to
waste your time because i'm proven dude
new york times bestseller my first
book's five star rated on amazon and i
have no doubt this one will be two so
get the autographed copy right now by
pre-ordering it at stevo.com
yeah dude